قال وزير الخارجية أنتوني بلينكن إن
الولايات المتحدة وافقت الآن على إصدار تنازل
يسمح للبنوك بتحويل 6 مليارات
دولار من الأموال الإيرانية المقيدة إلى
قطر دون خوف من العقوبات،
وستشرف قطر بعد ذلك على دفع
أموال طهران التي لا يمكن استخدامها إلا لشراء المساعدات
الإنسانية.  السلع للبلاد حسنًا،
إنها جزء من الصفقة التي وافق البيت الأبيض
على إطلاق سراح خمسة مواطنين إيرانيين
محتجزين حاليًا في الولايات المتحدة
أو لمزيد من المعلومات حول هذا، دعنا ننتقل إلى
ناتاشا باكتروند من CNN في واشنطن، وقد استغرق هذا
بعض الوقت في الإعداد  إنه أمر
حساس ومعقد، ما
مدى السرعة التي يمكن أن نتوقع بها أولاً
سجن هؤلاء الأمريكيين حتى وقت قريب ثم وضعهم
تحت الإقامة الجبرية، وما مدى السرعة التي يمكن أن
نتوقع بها إطلاق سراحهم؟ ناتاشا
حسنًا، بيكي، هذا يبقى السؤال الكبير وهو
شيء كرره البيت الأبيض
مؤخرًا  الليلة والبيان
لنا هو أنه لن يتم
إطلاق سراح أي أمريكي هذا الأسبوع، لذا
بالتأكيد ليس هذا الأسبوع، لكن انظروا، كل هذا
يتحرك بسرعة إلى حد ما، لقد
توصلوا إلى هذا النوع من الاتفاق المؤقت
الذي يتم بموجبه وضع بعض هؤلاء الأمريكيين قيد
الإقامة الجبرية والآن  رأينا
أن وزير الخارجية أصدر
تنازلاً يخطر فيه الكونجرس بأن البنوك
في الخارج التي تحتفظ ببعض هذه
الأموال الإيرانية ستكون قادرة على تحويل تلك
الأموال إلى بنك في قطر ومن ثم
سيتم توزيع تلك الأموال إلى إيران
بالطبع بمجرد القبض على السجناء الأمريكيين.  يتم
إطلاق سراحهم حتى يتمكنوا من استخدام تلك الأموال
للسلع الإنسانية فقط، وهذا هو
المفتاح هنا الذي
سعت الإدارة إلى التأكيد عليه
وهو أن هذه ليست مجرد ستة مليارات دولار
تذهب مباشرة إلى
خزائن إيران، بل هي شيء
سيتم  تتم مراقبتها عن كثب ليس فقط
من قبل قطر ولكن أيضًا من قبل وزارة الخزانة الأمريكية،
وهذا لا يمنع
بالطبع الجمهوريين في الكونجرس
من انتقاد هذه الصفقة باعتبارها شيئًا
يشبه في الأساس دفع
فدية، وهذه هي الطريقة التي
صاغ بها الجمهوريون هذا الأمر وهو أنه لا يوجد  الطريق أمام
الولايات المتحدة للمشاركة في هذا النوع من
المفاوضات والصفقات مع إيران بحسن
نية فقط نظرًا لأنك تعرف كيف هي
العلاقات الإيرانية والأمريكية في هذه المرحلة وكيف
أثبتت إيران أنها ليست
شريكًا موثوقًا به في هذه الحالات ولكن
الإدارة  يشجعني
حقيقة أن هذه المفاوضات كانت
مستمرة ولذلك فهم يرون حقًا أن هذا
هو أفضل طريقة ممكنة في هذه المرحلة
لإعادة هؤلاء الأمريكيين إلى وطنهم بيكي